check this out this is a sunset on Pluto
it's one of the most recent stunning
images beamed back from NASA's new
Horizons spacecraft which is slowly
sending home postcards from its travels
at the edge of our solar system the
photo was made in July when the little
probe whizzed past the dwarf planet some
three billion miles away from Earth
let's look closer those are the Norgay
in Hillary Mountains peaks named for the
first climbers to summit verse Mount
Everest the flat plane is the Sputnik
Planum those rings are hazy layers of
Pluto's nitrogen atmosphere scientists
think there might even be some fog
hinting at a daily change in weather on
Pluto Earth's weather has a water cycle
on Pluto it appears to be a nitrogen
cycle see these worlds their nitrogen
glaciers pretty cool huh